[Music]
don't be a fake don't be a flake
don't run away from your feelings babe
don't be afraid
don't be ashamed don't hesitate to say
hey babe
hey babe hey babe hey babe
hey babe hey babe and the whole world
has to answer right now just to tell you
once again
hey babe what's up buddy what's going on
babe bad friends they got
they got it a bag of animal [ __ ] yes but
they didn't know it was animal poop
because
we here's what happened here's his tell
him what happened
what had happened was what had happened
was yes the bear friends podcast hosted
by the great andrew santino and the
great bobby lee
i don't know bobby ryan bobby
so so we sent them this gift as if to
say we're on the scene now
hey babe has arrived you just got hey
babe we wanted to nudge our friends want
to nudge our friends we got this
plan yeah from from my girl jasmine yes
sent animal poop to one of her
ex-boyfriends a few years ago we said
that's a fantastic idea to send to our
friends right take it back to the
beginning
someone you're dating as a general
practice sends [ __ ] in the mail to other
people
if you if you break our heart that's
what you're gonna get you're gonna get
up you're gonna get it back don't go
breaking uh
you'll get some elephant [ __ ] i woke up
breaking hey baby
so so what happened was is
we scheduled it me you and the great
homeless pam yeah the ones and twos as
always
week in week out we scheduled it to
arrive
right like an hour before they started
filming their episode like
but like like two like a week or two ago
right what happened was is there was the
delay in the shipment
it didn't come into a couple of hours
after they were done with the episode
and then sat in the scalding los
angeles heat inside their office for a
week for like a week for a week so i
have
i have a lot of questions and i'll begin
with whiskey
that is going to be tequila once again
once again it is a different tequila
it is a different tequila i can never
get those straight yeah
yeah it's well they yeah they're never
going to taste the same but
you know you just think if you when you
taste whiskey do you go
whoo one tequila two to kill three to
the floor i'm being honest with you
if you gave me a glass of my eyes closed
and said and i took a sip of that you
said is that whiskey tequila vodka beer
i know it's not beer but i wouldn't i
couldn't tell well this is this is a
sipping tequila and it's uh
it's aged a long time and it it doesn't
taste like you're out of the rack like
give me a margarita it doesn't taste
like that so i
understand i don't want to come down on
you too hard there has to be a child
alive in this world whose first name is
tequila oh yeah 100 but they don't smell
like that they spell it t-a-k-e-e-l
oh for sure there's probably amazing
names out there tequila yeah tequila
hi my name's tequila tequila it's
actually not tequila it's
or tequila it took wheel is a name teal
tequila
they threw batteries at her they did
throw batters out at the uh
the juggalos they shouldn't have done
that no that's wrong you shouldn't throw
batteries anybody because
i mean at most at the most egregious
offense
a triple a no well triple a battery
maybe triple a battery that's still oh i
don't condone it
you draw you throw a you throw a single
a at somebody i mean you should go to
prison
there's no single a battery what are you
talking about this this triple a and
double a this is single a
there's no single a battery
a triple a nine volt nine volt thinks
who he is by the way
you can't just confirm why don't they
have a single a battery
what did you have a single a double a
triple a for the major leagues what does
this battery is duracell not in the
major leagues what did you think a
single a battery looked like
i thought it was just a pretty big
battery that's a d
c are you thinking of a c a c is a
smaller d
but there's no b by the way a b battery
there is none
it's just it goes from an a to a c to a
d it's a b attitude
b attitudes you're giving me a b
attitude you're giving me a b attitude
we'll talk religion later oh no no we're
going to talk about lent don't you worry
that's what you should name your new kid
if he's a boy lent lynch
lent is a cool name lance like a rap
name
like like he just give it up for lent
oh my god oh don't anyone steal that no
this is it can this be copyright law
because it aired
oh my god are you kidding me give it up
for you i'm let's give it up for me
give it up for lent here you know what
let's i mean everyone's just like
yeah let's call right now let's let's do
this right now because
literally hold on we're gonna i'm gonna
call my pregnant girlfriend six months
right now
i will say hey i will help hey
hey what's up listen um sal and i yeah
hey
we're doing the we're doing the pod here
and sal just came up with a fantastic
name for our unboxing fantastic jazz
okay so here it is lent we name the
child lens and then it becomes like some
type of
musician or actor and you say give it up
for lens
what do you think
i knew you were gonna say that all right
give it up for lent so uh so we're gonna
name the baby lent
definitely not all right bye all right
um so i like the name lent but let's get
back to bad friends
what happened was yes the poop stayed
and melted and we had a note
that said from the company i forgot the
company's name we used
that i have problems with the company
i'm gonna i'm gonna add the grievances
here go ahead
go for it go ahead i mean senders.com
boopsenders.com
okay we i was under the impression from
the poopsenders.com website right
that and correct me if i'm wrong but
maybe i'm where is that gonna come like
a little bit more professionally
like i thought it was in maybe a jar
that's what i thought we paid for a
mixture of multiple animals
poop we paid for i believe it was monkey
elephant and i think something exotic
was it maybe tiger
we got the valentine's day uh combo pack
which was all their best poop
yeah right which was i believe it was it
was certainly monkeys certainly elephant
i forgot what the last animal was right
now right now it was rhino
so we thought it was going to come i
thought it was going to come out in a
keepsake mason
right and the note was supposed to say
to our friends hey
you've been hey babed right you know
that's a fun little little thing little
thing fun little thing and uh it came in
a gallon-sized ziploc freezer bag
squashed down to a sin sheet yes
and it it was sent in a united states
postal service regulation letter
envelope it's as genuinely as if what i
really think happened is i don't know if
it's because of covert maybe they're
under understaffed
it's just it's as if they got an order
couldn't believe they got an order had
no poop so one of the employees [ __ ] in
a ziploc bag
and sent it to the bad friends well
what's the deal with bad friends also
smelling it and being like we're not
sure if it's poop how do you mistake
poop i talked to andrew santino he was
like
it smelled horrible and rotten but i
couldn't i couldn't necessarily
say if that was poop now santino and
bobby lee have said that they're going
to get us back and they're going to pay
us back big
yeah so this is like they're saying it's
like an east coast west i just hope i
don't end up
with bullet holes in me and in a car on
the vegas boulevard yeah las vegas
yeah because you know cause shout outs
shout out shout out big thanksgiving
um great martial i was talking about ken
who are you talking about who's ken
who died big who's biggie oh biggie the
rapper biggie smalls the notorious uh
b.i.g
chris wallace christopher wallace
christopher by christopher
that's true hmm this hits you this
this hits you right in the chops it gets
you hard but i have 600 calories left on
my fitness so
um you've been you've been up in the gym
just
working on your fitness yeah yeah yeah
you do podcasts and then and then chaos
there's something there wait what what
fergie fergulicious
yeah and my rhymes are so ridiculous
and if you get the fictitious oh my [ __ ]
is trump
shout out if you want to come up open
invite right yeah oh yeah she could come
on
you gotta call fantastic
you show up with a negative culvert you
come right up two forms of id
and co and a negative code yeah because
who knows i mean just because someone
shows up at the door how do i know she's
stacy ferguson don't look at there he
goes did i get that don't look at the
screen do not look at the screen because
you can stop i just want to ask i swear
to god you have my heart
we talked we talked about how we both
went to catholic school
not only grammar school not only high
school but also college we both i went
to
from kindergarten to senior year of
college the senior year of college yeah
now
you also said that you taught ccd you
did
i want me to blow your balls right off
please okay
uh as a senior in high school monsignor
farrell boys catholic
okay i taught catechism to public school
kids
for extra credit right for the full
semester
for the full year i taught third grade
catechism two years in a row okay
so i can get college credits i don't
even know what the credits were for
right i guess religion class i don't
even know
and i on tuesdays i got to get out of
school
like three hours early go to saint
mary's parochial school
in rose bank okay and then that's when
they would ship in the public school
kids
right when the other kids had half day
once once a month or once a week
whatever it was
and i would teach i had a i had a binder
with a lesson plan
right and i was like a real teacher okay
and i taught catechism can you believe
that now do you want to know
yes can you take a guess how old the
children are
that i taught in 1994 how old are they
right now how old are the children i
taught in 1994
how old are they or will they be turning
this year because it was that's their
class
um 30. the kids that i
taught will be
they're 35 turning 36 in this year
2021 you would be teaching me you i i
taught you
catechism can you believe that well
here's
this is it now we have 35 turning 36
this year
the pupil and the man the yes can you
believe can you
imagine i taught you catechism dude well
i i got into my senior federal high
school i just didn't go my mother was
about to send me to go live with my
father who lived on staten island yeah
and i was going to go to him i got into
archbishop malloy which i went to
and monsignor farrell high school which
was my second choice and
i was going i was accepted into both and
i was going to go to farrell
and live with my father but then at the
last minute it was decided
not to do that and i stayed by my mom
but let me ask you this yeah because you
taught cats
you talk catechism you're being a little
arrogant about it you're you're you're
thinking who you are
you think you're thinking who you are
well you know
some of us just people that you know
there's people that teach catechism and
there's people that don't know
you've you've from you know for the last
hour since we've been talking about
catholicism before the podcast
you've had a major be attitude with me
and i just want to ask you how this is
quiz questions
yeah i'm gonna i'm a back-to-back quiz
question
don't look at the screen i'm not how
many beatitudes are there
[Music]
you're letting the these people aren't
they're they're looking at you as a
teacher
but i don't know if like i taught
beatitudes that year if you're
i didn't teach you but there's eight
years like the kids go to catechism from
like eight years
so like my beatitudes i don't know what
year it is but it might not have been my
year
like i might have never spoke beatitude
out of my mouth really
yeah i don't know i don't even remember
what a attitude is wow
i don't even remember i have a newbie
attitude i'm looking good from my head
to my shoes
nowhere
my guess is it taylor dane
[Laughter]
for theirs is the kingdom of heaven hold
on hold on hold on i don't know what is
the be attitude
here we go beatitude inherited its
blessedness from the latin word betus
meaning both happy and blessed in the
bible the beatitudes are a series of
eight blessings such as blessed are
those poor in spirit theirs is the
kingdom of heaven
and in 1958 writer jack korack coined
the term the beat
generation hold on hold on who
jack korack no you know who that is
right
famous beatnik author on the road
k-e-r-o-u-s
but you know who that is that's and i
don't want to sound like jack
jack he owns he owns sorak vodka
are you serious well he's he's a lineage
his great great great great his own
series people when he was a kid called
him jack karakomolli
guracamole like guacamole i'd say
at least two people did yeah jack
kerouac
who's jack kerouac he's one of the most
famous beatnik poets and writers of all
time
pam be 100 honest with me don't spare me
anything have you ever heard of jack
kerouarek
wow well now you change it first you
thought it was karak
then karak iraq and then you're saying
kirowak
what do you say the name again jack jack
uh
kate pull it over a little bit k k e r
o k e r o u a c jack
jack karaoke
it's jack kerouac jack kerouac now don't
get me wrong
i'm not like i mean i'm not like i'm not
gonna go off on
everything he's done and i'm saying on
the road and that's like saying oh
arnold schwarzenegger
terminator but he's part of the beatnik
generation you know the beats
but i didn't know i'm sorry what's the
beatnik
those are like the hippie dippy people
that came out of like i know for sure
like new york and the west village
that were like these authors and poets
of a certain generation
and they their prose was like cut from
the same cloth
like i think what maybe ginsburg right
um
who else i mean but but you're they're
saying that the okay beat nick you've
heard the term beatnik
i've heard beatnik but i thought that
was a rap group the beatniks no that's
the beat nuts
watch out now that's the beat nuts no
the beatnik a young person in the 50s
and early 60s
in the 1950s and early 1960s belonging
to a subculture associated
with the beat generation the beat
generation was like i don't even know
what that really it's like hippies
no it says what's the difference between
a beatnik and a hippie so it's not like
if you can go down a little bit pimpy
right there what's the difference
between a beatnik and hippie hippies and
beatnik share many of the same beliefs
they are fundamentally different groups
now
where beatniks tend to keep a low
profile and expressing themselves with
dark simple clothing
the hippies re reveled in maintaining
individuality with each different color
for comics so their fashion
you know hippies had you know the tie
dye and the bell buttons beat nick you
know beatnik
is a mock black turtleneck ray
right this way got it little little list
going on little uh though
like a wire glasses like a hipster
yeah got it but he took that from the
beatitudes
did they come from the bible did jack
trying to name a beatitude
it seemed like his reference okay should
we should we have our own beatitudes for
the pod 100
i'd like somebody to go make the
beatitudes maybe we should do we should
do 88 beatitudes of hey babe
let's do it well the hey bib
commandments like the ten crack
commandments shout out
again yeah are these these are the
haters these are the ten hey babe
commandments
they hate babe attitudes to hate beyonce
let's read these beatitudes and let's
see if we jibe with them
blessed are the poor in spirit for
theirs is the kingdom of heaven uh
okay so if you're poor in spirit so that
does that mean you could be you have
cash money out the ass but you're poor
just in spirit i think if you're poor in
spirit
i think you're down on your luck down
you're you get in the kingdom of heaven
blessed are those who mourn for they
shall be comforted god bless okay
blessed are the meek for they shall
inherit the earth now what meek is a
makes out meek milf philadelphia rapper
well he took over so he that's
he me meek mill was his success is due
to the third be attitude here you go
fourth blessed are those who hunger and
thirst for righteousness for they shall
be filled
so forget about my fitness palap you
need to be thirsty and count your cows
of righteousness
right so you're if you have a drive to
to do right
did you write that will come back number
five blessed are the merciful for they
shall obtain mercy
and now i feel like they're getting a
little weak because it's like now
they're like blessed are the mercy folk
because then it will give you mercy
we need jack corraco yeah
yeah shout out shout out caracas um uh
venezuela
yeah um blessed are pure in heart for
they shall see god
pure heart which which you and i i think
are getting there but we do have high
cholesterol
and you know debatable blood pressure so
i don't know i wouldn't before i could
see god i'm gonna have to get a full cat
scan 100
yeah and i'm gonna yeah i'm gonna have
to ask you to keep taking your omega-3s
yeah blessed are the peacemakers not the
pacemakers blessed are the peacemakers
for they shall be called children of god
so the children of god are the
peacemakers uh and then number eight
last but not least blessed are they
which are persecuted for righteousness
sake for theirs is the kingdom of heaven
so you get persecuted for being
righteous you're also getting into
heaven
so it's it's so it seems relatively easy
to get rules
are these rules these are the beatitudes
this is the beatitude you need to take
in
every day i want you to wake up with
this beatitude okay look at me right now
okay re give me one beatitude of the
eight word for it
um um you guys you got you can't just
you gotta
you gotta you gotta soak it in right
there yeah i'm gonna look
you know you should you should we should
all be coming away from today
being able to at least recite one be
attitude i'm gonna do the best in the
conversation
keep in mind i've been drinking mm-hmm
yeah you've had yes
you've been drinking that's a lot for me
that's a true statement
you have been drinking yeah it's how am
i well you didn't ask me how much i said
i've been drinking out of drinking
that's correct
blessed are the meek
what do they get what do the meat get
for they
they get grammys blessed are the meek
the kingdom of heaven is theirs
is that it blessed are the me for they
forget about the beatitudes name me oh
there's ten of them
so i'm asking you as a cat as a as a
teacher of the catechism
to name me five of the ten commandments
i just want five okay here's what i
think we should do
yeah well do you feel like you know them
or you don't know for sure i'm
relatively confident i could get five
okay i feel like maybe i can get five so
why don't we do this
why don't we make a bet we'll make a
wager on ourselves that we can name
all ten commandments right now okay
okay okay and then what do we what do we
win
do we win something um wanna go
commandment for commandment
we'll go command for commandment okay
whoever whoever gets stumped up it
doesn't have to be in order
okay commandment whoever gets stumped
though okay that's it
okay whoever gets stumped whoever has a
terrible you have to get but they have
to get butt naked dude podcast butt
naked
that's so fair yes yes okay okay
go ahead you go first okay well okay
so if you get it wrong and it's not an
actual one you're done you're done
it doesn't have to be it doesn't have to
be word for but you have to at least get
it okay
so pimp yeah pull them up pimpy okay go
ahead you go first
thou shall not covet thy neighbor
is that right your their neighbors
their neighbors their neighbor's
significant other life partner no it
says wife but wife or husband
no but but the commandment is thou shalt
not cover thy neighbor's wife
no specifically yes don't look yet but
i'm telling you specifically
but but they don't mention
coveting the husband no because women
were with that commandments were written
in date
it was about the patriarchy baby moses
didn't give a [ __ ] yeah but eve bit the
apple
they didn't care yeah but yeah so we're
all we all have we're born with
originals no listen i'm not
i'm not listen do i think do i think
it's a little outdated
what i did and i think it should be fair
i gave you a 20 21 commandment
don't covet thy neighbor fine period i'm
going to give it to you but i'm just
saying texas
so if if if if i get married one day and
my wife covets my neighbor's husband
right she's not sinning technically in
the eyes in the eyes of
the law of the kingdom of heaven she's
not sitting because it's not unless
the husband gets sex change it becomes
the wife let me ask you this
what if my one day i get married my wife
covets my neighbor's
wife a wife she is sinning i think she
is sinning then
because you can't go gay in the old
testament unfortunately okay
now you could go gay now we're proud to
go so women could covet men
till the cows come home 100 and they're
not sinning not but the second a woman
covets another woman
yeah so you know it needs to be it needs
to we need a newer testament now
i'm not sick we need like the newest
testament let's do that yeah yeah like a
w like a woke
like yeah like the book the book of woke
let's do the ten crack commandments yeah
yeah we should we should start to name
those two
because yeah i could get a couple of
those okay so don't don't don't cover
this don't cut my neighbors wife
here's an easy one thou shalt not kill
oh that's a big one
that's the biggest one yeah that's like
that's you brought out the biggest one
right there
shall not kill us i think the universal
one that's that would be the most
popular one
i got enough i got a i got another one
in my head dashing out
the astronaut steals another big one
thou shall not take the lord's name in
vain
yeah yeah like you can't say you can't
say jesus christ
like yo jesus christ or god damn it i
apologize
that one is insane it's insane
it is insane that don't kill and don't
take the name in vain
are in the same top ten list yeah okay
that's crazy
yeah that's like putting i won't even go
there with this podcast i won't even go
there
all right so okay that's so that's good
yeah so so so now
so could you imagine god like god or
saint peter is at the gates two people
come up and they're like
and he's like you just you you stab
someone neck they died in front of that
family
and you said jesus h christ both yes get
in there you crazy kids get it yeah yeah
no they both get the elevator down they
put it down yeah but they're both
they're both they both committed the
same sin
yeah the same level of sin because they
didn't they didn't wait
they didn't put weight to the
commandments no right they just
moses came down and said god spoke to me
in a burning bush
and i i scribbled these on stones where
he got a pencil in
in bc god knows yeah only god does yeah
i broke a commandment
yeah he couldn't go was he was god
dictating as he did that was he
yes god was dictating because then god
was like let's just
let's speed this along because you know
how long it takes to write thou
shall not take the lord's name in vain
by chipping stuff out with him
i wonder if there was actually there
might have been 25 commandments god
bailed out he was just like
you know what he was like how much we
have 10 10 because my my friends wait
you know what it is too it's like it's
it's it's
the commandments if i was moses i would
have been like
i'll just i'll just memorize them yeah
i'll just memorize them i'll go down
i'll relay i'll relay
word of mouth yeah yeah no but he wanted
to chisel okay thou
shall not okay steal kill covet the
husband and cover the wife
cover the significance lord's name in
vain right how can this be harder than i
thought
we have fought shall not thou shall not
thou shall not thou sh oh thou shall
honor the sabbath yes right it's not a
not it's
thou shall on his shoulder are we pimp
is pimp are we are we on track have we
gotten five like good ones because i
don't want to look
yeah yeah you guys are doing great so
that's one thou shall honor the sabbath
[ __ ] black sabbath
um thou shall thou shall not
why'd he have to labor they i know
that's a good one yeah
thou shall not eat meat on fridays um
no that's not it i know that you weren't
saying that
so that's not your guess what about thou
shall not sin
that can't be one thou shalt sin
everything
these are the sins thou shalt
if i was moses i would have heard old
man like how about i just tell them not
to say i think there's one
isn't there one thou shall not buy an ox
or something like that there's something
about an ox in there
thou shall not that shall not buy an
oscar not something with an
ox or a mule have sex with no no no
animal sex yeah i think it's thou shalt
shall not thou shall not
commit adultery with thou shall not
commit adultery that's one so we've run
into one issue here with sal's
uh you should not covet your neighbor's
wife yeah you combine
two different things there what i do
it's you sh you uh shall not commit
adultery and also another one is you
shall not covet
oh i always covet thy neighbors blah
blah blah i thought but here let's just
look now
no no don't look oh well we'll cut all
the dead air
okay because so that's how do they so
so you shouldn't covet anything i mean
like i should covet me
i think it's like like like covet means
to like desire like
almost like jealous like uh envy envy
right so i think it's more like if you
drove up in like a new volkswagen
beetle and i was like oh i want that for
me i'm covering your beetle
god you covered my understanding so i
shouldn't cover your beetle
or your wife got it okay okay
how about there's gotta be another big
one like thou shall not like
you know punch or something like that
like you can't just be killed
i have thou shall not commit adultery
he's my next one right but i'm saying
like there's got to be
lie cheat steal i said steal something
about the lie
thou shall not thou shall not worship
false god
worship false gods so now we're is are
we pimp are we getting a check
false false gods right we're at seven
okay
is there anything about an ox thou shall
not is it not
thou shalt not worship false gods
false false um it's not god's they call
them something else
idols maybe yes idols yes thou shalt not
say worship false idols okay
okay i'm sorry that means i have to we
have to stop worshiping whitney houston
because she's not god this needs a
rewrite
that's debatable the newest testament
somebody do it who's gonna who would
write the new te who would write the new
commandments right now would it just
give me
the newest yeah elon musk just give it
to him
he'd have to do it who else is going to
do it elon musk or joe rogan write the
new one yeah
yeah i can get it i can't find it i'd
like to see tim i'd like to see what
they are
yeah tim dillon writes the commandments
funny about it the locusts are coming
[Laughter]
all right so we have three left thou
shall not
is it like have
sex before marriage is it pimp
no thou shall not thou shall not
thou shall not don't like look at your
neighbor's wife
don't give don't give shall not give
dirty looks
no i think it's something like donald
trump his wife my neighbor's wife a
dirty look
um don't even look thou shall not even
look at my neighbor's wife
i don't know i don't know i don't know
what the rest of these are i
thou shall not maybe is it thou shall
not thou shall not sacrifice
something like are you sure there's
nothing with an ox in there
thou shall not have an ox as a as a
personal pet
yeah i have to get allowed to have not
not know what it is i shall not eat that
shall not eat is it something like
that's not eating meat
thou shall not what about when that when
he got all mad remember jesus got mad he
went to like the flea market
and everybody was like and he flipped
tables over yeah everybody
everybody remembers god's cannot word
jesus maybe like
oh oh oh oh oh oh oh so think of that
agreed
uh uh glo blah blah blah blah blah blah
seven sins gluttony blasphemy we could
gluttony blast
seven sins seven deadly sins gluttony
blasphemy
greed breed lust lust
envy envy covet
whichever one you can't get you got a
tattoo right here right over the eyebrow
i wrote a paper in college on the
seventh deadly sense did you and there
was a movie about it
brad pitt seven right they're the ones
what did they do
oh a river runs through it river runs
through it that was the one about the
sentence with
bradley pitt really [ __ ]
wait a river runs through is that the
one with meryl streep
i thought it was a brad pitt is brad
pitt bradley
there's there's not room for bradley
cooper and him
there he is runs through it oh this is
the one first movie ever did
what are the seven deadly sins pimp all
right let's we were we giving up
uh you know just if i wasn't drinking
i'd keep going
jesus christ just just
okay ten commandments you shall have no
gods before me is that
is that the same one though you shall
not worship a false idol
that's the same thing oh no no oh he's
doubling down
on it moses you killed your father and
your mother
oh my god keep the sabbath holy
don't murder what the hell's that we got
a big what is that
that's a big bug is that a fly that is
is that a fly you think that's a you
think that's a locust do you think
you shall not covet you sean biff don't
bear false witness against your neighbor
like that what the hell does that mean
like don't don't lie about your neighbor
don't bear false witness
you know what we should start talking
like this yeah i want to get into like a
we'll get into a blah fight one day
and come home and john's like what's
wrong you're like bearing false witness
against me
[Music]
here you go the weirdest rules in the
bible number one weirdest rule this is
true when fighting another man
chop off his wife's hand if she grabs
your genitals
what that's not in the bible that it's
legitimate when men strive together one
with another and the wife of the one
draws near
for to deliver her her husband out of
the hand of him
the smitheth him that smites him and
puts forth her hand and taketh him by
the secrets
oh the secrets are your genitals are you
genitals so she's saying you get into a
fight with another man
his wife tries to grab your balls cut
her hand off cut her hands off
we need a newest test how about this
don't sit where a menstruating woman has
sat
that's you know and i mean you know if
you're wearing white pants
you read the top and i'll read the
passage okay let me ask you this
yeah if you wanted to go on a website
yeah right and let's say you're
searching on you for your favorite
website you're looking for your favorite
michael strahan cop favorite you
mako straight hand face i have my tea
with a little honey in it got your tea
with a little honey in it yeah
imagine when you checked out there was a
button
that you could press with a drop down
menu that would scour the internet
for coupons and it would hit it would be
it would say apply coupons
and you could get a coupon you'd be
you'd think you're paying
full price for the michael strahan cup
but instead you're going to get to apply
a coupon
by going to this certain website called
honey
honey it's called honey can i be frank
with you honey
you can do whatever you want i'll tell
you right now and this is the god's
honest
i online shop a lot i know i online shop
till i drop
right and every single time i check out
and i'm not sometimes we get an ad and
you know
i'm like oh this is a but this is true
yes i
when there's a thing for a promo code or
a discount to be applied
yeah i always search right and i go
through the whole rigmarole the first
five links and you cut and paste and it
doesn't work
yeah because even if i i just never like
getting over someone getting over on me
so i want any discount
i scour i am successful one out of ten
times if there was a product no joke
that would do that for me in the click
of a button and
and solve that problem i i'm looking
look at me look at me
i would punch my own mother in her
throat wow swear to god well there is a
product and it's called honey honey
honey
honey h-o-n-e-y that's exact product mrs
volcano get ready to get your throat
punched out
because honey exists it's literally you
just joined for free it's a free thing
and it installs it's an app it installs
and it's your second app that's going to
save you money
it's free and then everything you order
you save money on same and you can just
save money
on anything you're buying clothes tech
headphones the other day and i was like
you know um
just gonna buy them and then you know
because i saw that they were coming as a
sponsor i said what's this and i did the
honey.com thing
and i say 15 on the headphones i'm gonna
i'm not joking i'm going in and i'm
downloading it right now prove it
welcome to endless savings from your
favorite stores let's get started
boom we talked to talk with then you'll
join and you're going to put in hey babe
somewhere over there what's that
you find us you do hey or you go honey
for free at joinhoney.com
hey babe that's all you got to do but it
literally is one of these things
one of the i mean lit it scours the
internet
for coupons it's truly one of the things
that makes your life easier with zero
effort
yeah yeah it's amazing hello yes hey
listen to what i'm no no what do you
mean what happened
uh i called you and they hung up i was
calling you in hang on
you called me it's here no there mom
i got a punch in the throat
i gotta punch you in the throat it's
gonna it's listen long story short
there's an app called honey
it's gonna save me money and i didn't i
thought it was too good to be true and i
said if it's true
i'll punch my mom in the throat and you
know that you raised me to be a person
of my word so
i know it's gonna come and see you this
weekend just be prepared
what are you talking about
wear neck brace see you later mrs v bye
join honey dot com slash hey babe that's
all you got to do real quick
did you know that your teeth have skin
it's called enamel right it's cool
right enamel yeah there's this cereal
that i eat it's called magic spoon
yeah it is the i'm being dead serious
it's the best cereal
i've ever tasted in my life i'm being so
serious
it's healthy you know me with logging in
all my calories yeah it's got such few
calories
the only thing is when i eat it for some
reason it makes my teeth feel heavy it
almost makes me like my teeth feel like
they have skin
really yeah and this is a pleasurable
though 100 pleasurable yeah so you feel
like you have extra enamel
on your teeth yeah and they're not
telling you to say this they're not
telling me trust me
they're not telling them to say this
yeah but this is then a
good thing it's a great thing magic
spoon cereal no i'm being serious
yeah i've got four boxes up to the house
i went to magicspoon.com
hey babe yeah put in the promo code hey
babe yeah and i got five dollars off
i genuinely bought magic spoon with our
own promo code i swear to christ
i got the the um the cocoa one and there
was the blueberry
fruity peanut butter my daughter loves
it i couldn't get my my daughter won't
eat anything my daughter hasn't eaten in
three weeks
she only eats magic spoon i i didn't
know i didn't even put it on our own
promo code yet i want to order how do i
do it
go to uh magicspoon.com hey babe then
put in the promo code hey babe
and you'll get five dollars off but
genuinely dude it's first of all it's
got 14 grams of protein you know i'm
trying to get jacked
zero sugar you know i'm not trying to
lose any more feet only four net grams
of carbs
and it's only 140 calories a serving
and i'm telling you when i eat it my
teeth feel heavy and it's a good thing
wow that's it so you heard it right here
magispoon.com
slash hey babe put in the promo code hey
babe if you want your skin
to feel like it's growing on your teeth
absolutely
so one thing i think you deserve
please with all that you've done in your
life all the success you've had all the
all the friendship that you and
i've had for all these years and how
much of a great friend you've been to me
you deserve to know what you're putting
in your body
and from this point forward from this
point forward all i want you to put in
your body
are vegan-friendly multivitamins and the
place to do that
is ritual ritual okay ritual we do we do
deserve to know what we're putting in
our bodies especially when it comes
does danger you know what's not in
ritual what you won't find it
sugars gmos major allergens synthetic
fillers and artificial colorants you
won't find it
that's not a ritual you won't find it in
there funny you should say that because
i got
ritual that they sent it to my house i
i'm literally
i've been taking this it's like a
multivitamin i'm feeling great the
ritual i said
i said that i said where's the color in
this multivitamin all my other
any other multivitamins this color is
that color it's there's no color you're
not going to get it and you're not going
to have to go to the store to buy ritual
because it's a subscription-based
service
sent right to your door so that's taking
out all that time and energy so
literally you don't have to think twice
about it they know when the supply is
going to end
because they got a time just like your
time release capsules release the best
nutrients right into your blood system
they have ritual.com you go to
ritual.com hey babe
get 10 off your first three months visit
ritual.com hey babe
to start ritual today and i'll tell you
nothing i like that they do they they
have the ingredients in it as traceable
so you know where all the stuff is
coming from which i i don't really know
how many people are doing that right now
you'll always know what nutrients you're
taking and where they come from
thanks to rituals one of a kind visible
supply chain
absolutely that's something else because
it's like you don't know where they're
sourcing this stuff
and it's available for women men and
teens so it's like who else do you want
to be available for goats
i mean literally i think they actually
have goats they have virtual goats
they do they might they don't it's a
suggestion friendly
friendly suggestion yeah ritual.com hey
babe
10 off your first three months okay
don't sit where a menstruating woman is
at leviticus 15 19-21 and if a woman
have an issue
and her issue is her flesh be blood she
shall be put apart seven days
and whosoever touches her shall be
unclean until the even
and everything that she lieth upon and
her separation shall be unclean
everything also that she sitteth upon
shall be unclean
and whosoever toucheth her bed shall
wash his clothes and bathe himself in
water
and be unclean until the even oh my god
leviticus man whoever wrote leviticus
needs to just wake up leviticus
oh my god leviticus is cancelled
leviticus is cancelled leviticus is not
a bad name for a kid
um women suspected of adultery have to
drink dirty water
so there you go women speak of adults
you gotta move to flint numbers
by the way what's up with flint's people
michigan i mean come on fix the water
numbers five eleven two thirty one if
any man's wife go aside
and commit a trespass against him and a
man lie with her
carnally and it be hid from the eyes of
her husband
the priest shall take holy water in an
earthen vessel and of the dust that is
the floor of the tabernacle the priest
shall take
and put into it the water this water
that causeth the curse shall go into thy
bowels
to make thy belly to swell and the thaw
and thy
thigh tender to rot wow i mean this is
absurd
and while they're saying they're saying
this is a complicated one some people
think the dirty water is supposed to
cause an abortion
others think it would be to pressure the
woman into a confession regardless
there's no
denying the idea was for the alleged
adulteress to drink a mix of holy water
and tabernacle floor dust
here we go don't wear clothes made of
both linen and wall well that can
we can keep that in the newest testament
that's just a fashion focus
five if your slave refuses freedom
pierce their ear well
all right skip that one skip that one um
you can't kill a burglar during the day
oh my god that's why that's why crime
run runs rampant at night at night
that's gotta be why because we're
religious people that's crazy dude yeah
that's really stemming from back then
that people like people were robbing
people in the daytime
what's the reason here if a thief be
found breaking up
and be smitten that he die there shall
there shall no blood be shed for him
if the sun be risen upon him there shall
be blood shed for him
for he should make a full restitution if
he have nothing then he shall be sold
for his theft
exodus 22 2-3 interesting
that fly is gonna it's bothering you huh
well it's gonna i want that fly i want
him i wanna i wanna i
want that flight i want that flight dead
i want his family dead
um here's number seven don't plant more
than one kind of seed in a field
all right so how much are these lights
pimp because they're about to get
knocked over
come on i just i'm just he's baiting us
he is basically you know what he wants
us to do he wants us to commit murder
he does what we want this has been sent
the fly has been sent here from jesus
yeah because he thinks that we're going
to commit murder he's a burglar too he
can get killed it's nighttime it is what
it is you notice how the fly was a
little sluggish
do you know flies is this true flies
live a day in the tip
a day no i think they live a day or like
a couple days
and that's it like if there's a fly in
here it'll eventually die without you
touching it after a couple days
28 days 20 or 28 days how come you never
find a dead fly on the floor then
can i tell you something yes one time i
went away on tour
and i came back three weeks later and
something happened in one of the ducks
and somehow somehow flies got in here
and i opened my front door and i found
almost 300 dead flies in this house
300 yeah i swept them up with a broom i
have a picture of it somewhere else
i'll patreon 300 i was gone for three
weeks so
i guess they got in toward the front end
of that and there was maybe like
15 to 20 flies still flying around but
there was
maybe two 250 flies dead all throughout
my house
and and so were my neighbors and other
neighbors i don't know what happened
everybody had flying some type of
biblical [ __ ]
happened three i was freaked out we
thought there was maybe like an animal
got into the ducks
and died there and then it rotted and
then like flies came
but we never as soon as you opened the
door there were dead flies everywhere
everywhere
they were mostly by the windows and i
just and i was like what the hell is
that and i look close i'm like flies it
was like
out of a horror movie you know how many
flies 250 and
and i'm not exaggerating there was about
250 flaws you had a pile of flies
i will find the picture because i have
them in a dust pan there's a mound of
flies it just looks like
i dumped out a box of raisins for this
wild fact yeah wait for this one but
tell you i'm ready
if you put all the humans on a scale in
the world
and all the insects on a scale the
insects will weigh more than the humans
no yep wow that's how many more insects
there are than humans
and we're talking about a lot of fat
humans
no you look good thanks man thank you um
do you know that
in new york city i think they say
statistically you're never more than
like a foot from a rat
really there's so many rats in new york
city per capita
yeah let's see we're in new york city
rat facts
it's an urban myth all right well
they've just gotten the best very first
one basically just said sal won't you
shut your mouth
shut your trap i'm lying i'm a false
witness against rats
no i i did read that how many rats were
in new york city
how how many rats how many rats in new
york city give or take i'm going to say
you want to guess 2 million rats 2
million
wow that's a great guess i'm going to
say more than that
wow it is a lot more than that is it 5
million
do you want me to tell you the answer
well you may pack up your stuff and move
right now
really 33.6 million rats in new york
city
you're telling me we're never more than
a foot away from a rat yeah did you say
it's an urban myth
33 million rats 33 million rats
is that the lottery guy yeah
new york city has 33 million rats
you ever see that so they could shoot
one commercial and keep changing the
dollar amount
wow chicago's more rat and faster than
us wow look at that
chicago finally beat us they're called
the ratties
they called the ratiest city in the u.s
wow
yeah no that's uh the fly thing is it's
almost like if
that happened to me and i had hundreds
of dead flies i would
consider that an omen by the way i
always i got freaked out by it
and then i was like what is going on and
i thought there was something dead in
the house
yeah and then i started calling my
neighbors and they were like we got them
too we got them too and i was like all
right
i never got them again for so long in my
life i would mix up
omen and homage so like there was a
point in my life i'd say oh my god mom
we got to move out this is a bad homage
[Laughter]
and i'd be like you know it's like from
the devil she's like you mean an omen
oh yeah and homage you're substituting
for omen oh man yeah homage
yeah just like oh i got i'm wearing you
know we love that company the home image
t-shirts yeah
at first i thought when you first
introduced me to that company i thought
it was common shirt yeah
i was like homage why are you wearing
that it's from the devil
houseflies live on a liquid diet okay
they can taste with their feet that i
knew interesting they defecate
a lot right so you've so we've all eaten
i think the average person
has eaten something like 10 pounds of of
human fee
fecal matter and fly fecal matter it's
stuck in the light now you
[ __ ] and pit that that fly is
[ __ ] and pissing everywhere
no the normal range for daily pooping
no this is a human being today three
times no no how how
how much how much [ __ ] does the average
person eat what are you googling
yeah let's see let's see
by the way we're supposed to be having
three bowel movements a day
yeah no i i thought that was for like
dogs i have one good one
every day where do you go i i feel like
i'm regular so i feel like one a day
one a day yeah i don't know one a day
i'm not a guy who does it in the morning
everyone's like oh you
you awaken the best things are morning
poop i don't think i've ever [ __ ] in the
morning
what's the longest you've ever gone
without it without a [ __ ] yeah
i don't think i've ever been like have
you ever been one i've had a i had a
friend that told me
he couldn't use the bathrooms on
vacation
my friend tim he told me that he went to
ireland one time was there for like nine
days
didn't poop till he got home really yeah
that has to be
genuinely painful where does it where
does all the food go
he ate for nine days where does that
food go i haven't i mean dude that's
that's yeah i went to the museum of like
weird science or something like that in
philadelphia and they had the man's
largest colon this guy died he had
something like 23 pounds of feces
wow stuck in his stomach just couldn't
he couldn't get it out yeah it was like
you know before
medicine or something um
yeah so we don't know but i think it's
something ridiculous how much
crap you eat um you know throughout the
course of your life like you you're
eating people's [ __ ] all the time you're
really you can't handle this fly i can't
i'm sorry i'm like i'm like
i'm like a cat i'm like i know sometimes
i wish i had like a lizard tug why
should just eat this
maybe i try to maybe i try to kill it
you want to do what you want to do i
mean you're taking life just understand
you're taking life during lent
he might have went into life blinded by
the light
you can't handle a fly not flying around
while we're trying to talk
i know it's tough who does this fly i
think he is i know or they
oh right i don't want to sign it yeah
not true true what is this funny thing
they are
um catholics right so
we we how do we start this part because
you came in here you started this
podcast with a major be attitude
yeah 35 years old uh i would probably
fail now that you tested me and i
couldn't even name the ten commandments
yeah i
probably would fail a test yeah talk to
me about the bible what do you think you
know
what do i know about the bible i know
that the old testament is
pretty much like what like like the jews
pretty much go by the old testament
and the new testament is more like the
new age hip like catholics will go by
the new testament mostly
jews live their life by the old
testament you you did sacraments a lot
of stuff oh yeah everything
up to everything up tonight up to
everything every uh is there anything
left besides
like when you're passing away in the
marriage what are the seven
seven blessed sacraments communion
baptism communion confirmation
confirmation anointing of the sick
um marriage
again i only got and then last right so
some [ __ ] last rites is sick
what is anointing of the sick anointing
of the sick is is last rights
oh it is already yeah yeah okay
reconciliation
the eucharist that's communion communion
what's this baptism confirmation
communion
anointing of the sick holy oh holy
orders if you become a priest
ah and then matrimony we talked about
this i told you i went to school with
the priest
no you didn't yeah i did what'd you oh
okay a kid i went to
i was with him from kindergarten through
eighth grade and we were like no joke we
i said this all right but he was going
to become a priest we
thought it and he did and he did and
then he runs that parish
right now he like he like came up from
the from the farm system
and then ran his own parish he is a
major league priest imagine that
that's cool should be in kindergarten
and being like one day i'll run the show
here
and then you do it by the way and i'm
you know i'm sorry if some people aren't
are catholic will listen to the podcast
i can't imagine we're getting anybody
but catholics listen
to the podcast i'm kidding um what
what what
what do people do now especially in in
covert time
no way everyone's drinking from the same
chalice anymore you're not drinking
jesus's blood
right with covet jesus blood is not it's
not the vaccine
right jesus blood has many things it's
not the vaccine for coving so how can
you
we all used to share a cup when we were
kids 100 people sharing the same cup
they would wipe it off with a little
rag i've never touched that cup ever in
my life what are you talking about never
once did i touch
how did you drink jesus's blood i didn't
drink his blood you only ate his body i
only ate his body
you would only eat jesus's body you've
never drank jesus's blood never in my
life did i drink his blood
also just answered a lot of questions
about the kind of person you are right
now well i have a question wait a minute
you as a child could drink the blood
i would drink jesus's blood it's just a
sip they would give children wine
i don't know why i'm having a mental
block here but when you went up
i remember he used to sip it and wipe it
with the cloth yeah no
no you're telling me that everybody was
backwashing into a chalice of wine
and the whole place was drinking the
same challenge i grew up listening
i don't know how they did on staten
island maybe you guys were drinking
jesus's juice we were drinking jesus's
blood
are you serious so that's why you when
you see people when they when they get
up to the front
and everyone has to come out when people
run they're probably like i'm not back
getting the back washer at the end of
the line well now
so i don't know what i don't know what
it is now but now is it
when jesus says blood do they just have
to divvy it up into little cups do you
have to
do you have to have jesus like maybe
they give like a little little wine
bottle
like a dentist yeah like the little
dentist cup let me ask you a question
did you ever
did you take the host like this yeah or
did you take it in your hand
and then you took a step to the left you
pivoted and then you took that hand you
put in your own mouth are you ready yeah
you're ready for i'm about to tell you
which is 1 000 true i may even have well
i don't know if i have video proof i can
ask my mom
we had an old school priest and an old
school communion teacher do you know how
i used to take
the eucharist on my knees with my tongue
out
like this oh come on on your knees yes
that's right you got on your knees up
front
and then they would put the weight while
everybody was behind you know what i'm
saying when i made communion oh when you
made it a ridge the first
no but even in my in my school that's
how we used to do it because you had to
bow
it was jesus's body so you had to like
pretty much you know get on your knees
and stick your tongue out i mean it was
wild
there's a lot of there's a lot of
questions now and what's happened with
the catholic church i'm like oh that's
why the benedictine citizen perpetual
adoration in clyde missouri are the
largest religious producers of communion
hosts
in the us that make up to eight million
wafers a month can i tell you something
else
i got a bag of hosts downstairs what do
you have a bag of community white for
school because i knew somebody let's
send that to us they need to repent
yeah they need to repent they need to
repent send them a bag of hosts
and let them do what they want um i had
someone who worked with the church that
was a friend of mine
and came over one day and said oh i got
i got some extra hosts
and i said i could take it he goes no no
they're not uh they weren't blessed yet
so it's not like everything's on the up
and up like they just they just wait for
form
once they're not jesus they're not jesus
body until the priests bless them and
make them jesus comes
so i'm not doing anything bad having the
actual wafer yeah i mean when these
things are shooting off the factory
lines they're not
jesus's body just yet no no no no no
they're just from the benedictine
sisters of uh missouri
so i got because because then i was like
oh i want to use these on the show
i just want to like go to people and
just like i didn't know what the bit was
yet
i wonder what how much how many calories
in my fitness pal community way for us
let's see right now because i think
they're low income i bet your community
waiver is a great
diet 25 calories i would say less i'm
gonna tell
say five calories how many calories in a
communion wafer
is it keto friendly point eight eight
calories per host so it's
less than a calorie it's like a tic tac
it's not gonna kill you
so we can't blame obesity in america on
catholics
you know how many how much jesus body
you'd have to get to
i mean you could eat 2 000 of jesus's
body a day and still
lose weight i really genuinely had a
friend
who his name is a great kid he could but
let's edit his name out i guess he's
great but yeah i'll just say okay
i had a friend i i think he'd be fine
with it but i had a friend who
couldn't stomach the taste of a
communion wafer and hand to god
used to bring like a little packet of
ketchup from a restaurant
and when he would take the communion
away from her get back together i swear
to god we get back to the pew
kneel down and then go like this and put
a dab of ketchup on and eat it
and i never thought it was weird because
he would just do it that's right
they put a little bit of ketchup on a
communion wafer wow
i think communion wafers like they taste
like they're actually regular wafers
right
it tastes like a rice cake yeah it
tastes like a rice cake yeah yeah i
wonder if nowadays though
and i wonder you know because you just
want to get people to church and you
know we're we're so
used to pleasure seeking could we get a
flavored could could we flavor up
jesus's body a little bit
right because cinnamon right right jesus
you know you don't know if he
necessarily tasted like a wafer they've
tasted they have all types of
lucy has different flavors magic spoon
has different flavors they all have
different flavors and they're both great
companies yeah
do you promote no but honestly if you
want to get younger kids in
maybe you want to do like a crayon razz
yes or like a pomegranate absolutely
or like a very berry a very very just
give them cutesy names
maybe maybe maybe pastel colors you know
those necco wafers
do you remember those when we were
little the necklaces they're like the
discs that are like
cell colors and they're basically just
like like a like kind of
like a i don't know old school candy
yeah make them like that see
make it like that they're like the
hearts right at valentine's day yeah
yeah
yeah i i i remember i haven't been to
church sometimes it messes
with me because my mother used to make
me go to church
every week and i would feel so guilty
and upset if i didn't go to church
and my daughter you know was baptized
but i don't make her
like we don't go to church anymore and
you know my mom's always like you should
be going to church like
you should be setting the example to
bring your daughter to church but i'm
like yeah but
i i don't want to go you know what it is
it's it is asking
a bit if you have if you have your hands
full especially like a family
kids job in our case sometimes three
four five jobs
right you know a pet or something it's
like right to get there and then
you know i was going to say too like
is the church moving to zoom now you
know what i mean
why don't we do that like that i bet you
that would bring in more people
worshiping on a regular basis but then
the church can't get the money how do
you get the donations it's all about
you know that they come and collect only
fans you know like they could do like
like why do the catholics die
that's a good idea sal he could do you
could literally give the freaking you
could give the
the what's it called the homily yeah
give the homily over the only fans
right and like you're a cam priest
you become a camp priest and everybody
pushes his watch from home and everybody
tips him the coins
ask your friend if he's if he would
start an only fans there you go and the
priest has destroyed the only thing
that's not the real priest is it
that oh okay i mean that priest is in
very good shape um
yeah no i mean that's that's a great
idea dude
honestly though if the if the catholic
church wanted to do like a full makeover
these are some ideas that they could
possibly use right you know just
flavored wafers
like make zoom zoom mass yeah one of the
best things to do
was because of the wooden the old wooden
in these catholic at least in my church
saint matthias
was to really rip a fart on those wooden
pews i mean
it would reverberate i mean you don't
understand
it would make i mean because the
acoustics are glorious
to hit the top of a gothic ceiling oh my
god
yeah you get in trouble yeah did you my
teacher used to yell at us if
when you kneeled when you went to kneel
did you kneel straight up or did you
lean your ass on the back of the seat no
you had to kneel straight up if you put
your ass on the seat she yeah yeah
she was like hey get it up get up judge
your son
okay real quick yeah can you name all
i'm asking for is seven of the twelve
apostles
matthew mark luke john okay matthew mark
luke john
also the four gospels uh
there's a big one uh the guy who
crossed the double crossed him he sits
at the end of the table
uh come on no no no no no
it's a band first name priest judas
judas priest judas matthew mark luke
john judith paul's got to be one paul's
got him peter
peter matthew mark luke john paul peter
there's one that everybody forgets but i
only know because i went to the school
judas there's a let there's a shoe in
last one
lent nope matthew mark luke john
peter paul judas how many
apostles are there 12. there were 12 but
i actually there's also an alternate
they had an alternate they had another
one no they did they had affiliates just
in case a guy just
just did a situation okay matthew mark
luke john peter paul judas and kappa
donna
[Laughter]
james james that's a big one james
right is that the one you went to school
no matthias
is not an apostle google is was saint
matthias an apostle
i don't even know this guy he was an
alternate apostle
he was an alternate yeah what do you
mean like if one of the apostles
couldn't make it yeah
yeah saint matthias here we go the acts
of the apa was according to the acts of
the apostles
uh a disciple who according to the
biblical acts of the apostle was chosen
to replace judas iscariot after judas
betrayed jesus
so he replaced judas science replaced
judas so who are the twelve apostles
right above it
here we go simon simon who's called the
chipmunks who's called pete
he's called pete who is called peter why
not just call him science why not just
call him simon oh because different
gospels you know where real quick
matthew mark luke and john these gospels
you know what the interesting thing is
they were all the gospels
they're named after the apostles but
they were all written nearly a hundred
years
after jesus lived so the amount of
streaming [ __ ] in these things is
probably next level
wow so none of these people who wrote
the book
it'd be like it'd be like if i was
writing a story about
1920 world war one from what my grandpa
said
but but so they didn't but the apostles
were jesus's right hand
but they didn't write it someone else
wrote the book of
and they wrote but who who wrote the
book of who wrote the book of
simon the book of peter no math no i
don't think matthew mark luke and john
were apostles they were gospel writers i
don't think they were apostles
oh so then who would i don't think so
wait bitcoin's going way down by the way
who actually wrote the bible according
to both jewish and christian dogma
the books of genesis exodus leviticus
numbers and deuteronomy the first five
books
of the bible and the entirety of the
torah were all written by moses
in 1300 bc we're talking about the the
the the four gospels
is new testament there is of course a
few issues with this such as the lack of
evidence moses even existed yeah
so now well that well because here's the
thing here's here here
here's the truth sal is there's other
bibles
there's one the dead sea scrolls there's
other bibles there's the there's the
gospel of um
it's like a sinister name but anyway one
of there are other
these are just kylo ren what kylo ren
kylo ren
yeah yeah there's there's yeah there's
the gospel of ted bundy
there's there's a lot of there's it was
all
chosen the gospels were chosen by
emperor constantinople in i believe 325
a.d
at it was called the council of nicaea
where pretty much what happened is the
catholic
religion as we know it today was just
chosen christmas was chosen
as the day the gospels were chosen which
makes jesus
look like the jesus we want to know
there's other gospels that say jesus was
married with children
it's absolutely you know all this but
you thought one of the commandments was
don't
knox yes okay
i mean you're going in a deep bible dive
right now
yeah and you were convinced oxen you had
to do with one of the ten commandments
yes
yes so i'm telling you so so that so
with that
that it was all kind of i'm not saying
what the catholicism we know today
is you know isn't it wow the people
people follow that by law today by law
but it's it genuinely was just
even even now shall not eat meat on
fridays right now during lunch
you meet on a friday you might go to
hell just like if you murdered someone
it's
the same thing yeah but that was at the
time and i'm forgetting the the king who
was in charge at the time that rule was
made
had owned a fish market and he owned all
the fish markets so he was pushing his
narrative
of e-fish whoa you know you can't eat
meat so he made a rule but now again it
is
it is so again not saying whatever you
want to think about your religion is
whatever it is
but i'm just saying the facts are that
these gospels
were all written a hundred years after
and they were just the four that were
chosen that made jesus
all look in a similar light none of
these other gospels say jesus was
anything negative but some of these
things that the you know
mary wasn't a virgin jesus did have a
wife and children
um there were other people at that time
at the time jesus lived
certainly a guy a man named jesus or
some type of messiah
complex person was alive at that time
but he was one of like
50 people alive at that time or in those
hundreds of years
saying i'm the son of god right so he
certainly is even more today
we don't even know exactly right exactly
so we don't even know so it's it's
pretty wide but the dead sea scrolls
yeah pretty wild well i know dead sea
the dead sea mud or whatever it is
salt salt that's a great exfoliant great
you're gonna pay a pretty penny but but
here's the thing with our blood pressure
issues can we get in the dead sea with
all that salt well
it's loaded with sodium do you think
that that will somehow penetrate our
skin and
affect our actual sodium levels osmosis
babe
i would love to swim there because you
know how buoyant that is now how fun it
would be to float without the tube how
about this
you ready for this effortless when we
get when this show really which by the
way
thank you to all the fans out there who
are supporting us i mean each week we're
going higher and higher in the charts we
we genuinely appreciate
the love and support we're getting so
much yeah we're being like we're
breaking all the lists now
yeah we're on all the all the podcasts
listen that's because of you guys
so thank you so much all girls or babies
when i say guys i mean
you're royal right it's the same thing
as coveting the neighbors
yes so so you but but
um um i think what we should do and if
the homeless pimp
would i mean the home swim needs to come
we should do a live episode floating in
the dead sea
we could do that why can't should we do
a gofundme how do we get there
patreon where is the dead sea is it open
in jerusalem
here we go i'm going to guess dead sea
the dead sea is in israel
right but yeah oh but where oh see the
jerusalem i'm going to say it's closer
to tel aviv
dead sea is also called the salt sea
salt jordan
jordan to the east israel to the west
what it is
the windows to the walls flights to
jerusalem let's see how much they're
going for these days oh you can get a
flight to jerusalem easy now but it's
going to cost you 18 plus hours yeah
they only got oh non-stop though in
american airlines 10 hours 40 minutes is
a non-stop flight to jerusalem
if you could fly i would actually think
i'd fly royal jordanian it seems a lot
more fun
royal jordanian you want to fly to a
country you want to fly
the airline that that country supports
right right when like you don't want to
fly
you know some other yeah you don't want
to fly spirit to freaking ireland you
want to go
air lingus yeah you've been over there
where dead sea yeah in the area
israel jordan jerusalem no i've never
been to that
time all right i thought you've been i
thought you've been over there because
you love
history no i've been to the uk i've been
uh you know
playing ireland i've been canada oh you
were in the uk i was thinking
i was thinking bethlehem for some reason
no no i've been about i've been in
bethlehem pennsylvania
yes shout out sam shout out that shout
out sand
pennsylvania check out casey jost by the
way oh yes casey josh
casey uh has done our new a lot of you
guys haven't heard the full thing yet
it'll get in your ear and it'll get he's
done uh
my buddy casey jost who i've been
working with for like a decade he works
on my show and stuff
he's a musician and he did the theme
song for us
right the new theme song and we
absolutely love it we're planning on
possibly filming
of like an opening for it like a
specific opening to that intro
right and it's we asked him to give us a
vibe when we told him
we said can you take like a rupaul meets
right said fred type vibe right like a
work meets i'm too sexy
right type we just wanted this like euro
like yeah and he delivered and it's
great and i and the more i play it
the more i love it he also did the taste
buds theme song
and he just did it out of the goodness
of his heart uh at casey jost
on all the social media he's a great
comedian great musician follow casey
give him some love
follow casey josie he gave me a great
tip once and he said his mother handed
it down to him
he for a snack for a nice healthy snack
he'll put peanut butter in a cup
and then and then take a banana and use
the banana as the fork
and the peanut butter in the cup but
you'll just eat the banana with peanut
butter therefore you you don't count the
calories on the bread you don't need
bread
because it's the act of dipping the the
banana in the peanut butter using it as
a utensil
you shave off 200 calories of white
bread and i just want to shout out casey
joe she really helped me lose some
weight
wow and casey and mrs jost so now you
just walk around with cups of peanut
butter
just shoving bananas into it saratoga
peanut butter only
that's right saratoga shout out shout
out we're working on those flavors right
now we're actually working on the
labeling we're working on the labeling
and the flavors
that's going on behind the scenes got
the taste buds yes i got a podcast
chrissy chaos if you guys want to go
over there check out my podcast i do it
for my couch
do it chrissy chaos has the podcast and
then you guys have if you've seen taste
buds if you haven't
oh it's on the no brush network taste
buds is another one so going back to bad
friends let's do it
uh they've declared a war against us
right um
we we uh we don't know what they're
gonna come at us with
i don't know what they're gonna come at
us with but i am i'm willing
i'm willing to i'll say this to bad
friends right now i'm willing to get
physical and violent
i'm willing if if they want to if they
want to take it to the next level
i'm willing to get violent i'm willing
to get arrested i'm willing to get
weapons involved
i'm willing to hire a hit team how funny
would it be if it's just a knock down
drag out
yeah like just white trash like weird
[ __ ] we scuffle
at the back of a of a discotheque like a
nightclub like a brat beef well here's
the thing if we're going to get if we're
going to get
in to a podcast war we just have to
somehow
figure out a way to keep king in the
sting
and fighting the kid out of it because
that's brendan chop who doesn't know who
you are
brendan shop
[Laughter]
no he doesn't want to be me he doesn't
want to be here that's brendan shaw
because pregnancy
job is if we get him involved in the
physical violent part he's got to find a
way to get brendan shaw on our team and
then we will physically attack bad
friends right
maybe we can get brennan just turn
around and just immediately physically
attack theo in their own pocket
yeah let's do that let's cause let why
don't we do that
why don't we try to do what russia said
i think we should send bert
and tom [ __ ] yeah let's see
i would say let's send bill burn bird
[ __ ] but i think bill burr may actually
take a flight across country
and truly ring your bell and be like
what is going on i'm not saying burst
[ __ ]
yeah i don't think i think that tom and
bert would get it i don't think bear
would appreciate it
i like keeping these podcasts on their
toes and
sending we should send something to
every podcast
let's make a list of like the 10 podcast
like 10 top like 10 that we
are friends with yeah and and maybe just
do it in one just send out a
wave of it a wave of it like so like
when they all get they all get at the
same time it'll be like the end of a
usual suspect yeah
like they just dropped yeah i kind of
like the idea of sending the communion
wafers
i like that i just keep it people like
what are they doing now what exactly
what
so how do you think they receive that if
we send them the body of christ i would
say to them it would say something like
you know uh they so they get it are they
so then it's the opposite they're not
like
[ __ ] this means war they're like the
body of christ
yeah you know maybe you're shuffled but
we don't say that we say we say
we say hey babe we've heard you've been
sinning oh
something like that oh we make it
ominous
or we think of something we we make it
like an homage
make it homage or we could just send
them the elevator yeah but then they're
going to send that in a plastic bag i
mean poopsanders.com
what's up with that how do you send poop
to them in a ziploc bag put into a an
envelope for a letter
if you guys if anybody out there owns a
company that sends animal [ __ ] or human
[ __ ] in a nice
jar let us know because we'd like to
we'd like your services
you could ship a live animal but what if
we ship a pig or something
what if we ship a live animal and say
what's up you
you pig to a podcast give him a live pig
a live one you could ship live animals
you can't ship a live animal it just
says shipping live
animals come on dude come on ship a live
animal
it's just how to safely shipped
i just saw shipping right there was on
you back out right there shipping live
animals
that's not but that's like if you want
to like send your dog to your aunt and
see okay okay that's too much that's
that's like more like how do you
you're moving acro if i want to send you
you know i don't know i get divorced my
wife was across the country i sent her
the dog
right right that's not like shipping up
like a barn house pig to a podcast
we're breaking commandments we are
breaking right thou shall not
we're doing one of the commandments of
breaking by doing this thou
shall not i mean are we coveting in a
way we're coveting
yeah no are we coveting well we're not
coveting
we're kind of yeah i guess we're not
coveting
should we should we send the salmon are
we going to trust
poop senders to send the sandwich you
know we should in the salmon we should
send the salmon from hello fresh
promo code hey babe that's true hello
fresh you send them a salmon
sandwich you want to send them a raw
fish right on the same page
yeah yeah okay all right cool so we're
just starting
podcast wars we're starting podcasts
right by sending
we could send nice gifts too like we we
said you know yeah we're sending them a
salmon
we'll we'll get creative with it okay
you know king and the sting we could
send them a
whole thing of honey okay we can send
them with live bees
let's send them angry bees let's send
them beatitudes
beatitudes well just a bunch of bees
that are pissed off
yeah they have attitudes that's what it
is king in the sting
the king in the sting sting is the king
is theo this thing is
brendan i don't know is that what it is
i thought it was the other way around i
have no idea oh really because i figured
the sting like you
when you you stinging is the act of but
then also
the king i mean he's a ufc fighter but
then why is steel to sting
i don't know he has a weird hair i don't
know
yeah yeah he's got a i don't know all
right well what can you do
it's okay you can't do anything about it
every i want you people out there
who listen to the show thank you very
much have a good beatitude
uh at work today um don't give your
family members be attitudes
and follow the commandments try to be a
good catholic good kid
that's it i'll uh hey tonight it's
thursday tonight i'm in phoenix right
now i'm in phoenix tonight
all the shows are sold out we added a
late thursday night show there may be a
few tickets left for the thursday 9 30.
so if you're in phoenix come right now
come to the show 9 30 but all of them
the rest of them are sold out baby
what can you do i love it baby i love it
babe i love it just go to the show don't
cover them
don't cover it just go to the show and
laugh don't covet it and i'm gonna i'm
gonna try to i'm gonna try to convince
my girl to name our kid lent give it up
for lent
give it up for lent it's just so good
right i could use a communion wafer
right now you wanna go eat a wafer
let's go i have them okay
don't be a fake don't be a flake don't
run away from your feelings babe don't
be afraid don't be ashamed don't
hesitate to say hey babe
hey babe hey babe hey
[Music]
we should really do it i'll poop in a
bag for real and send it me too you want
to [ __ ] around east coast yeah you got
oh
really yeah oh really new york